we have been supporting people with
real-time innovation sessions in which
we are using all of this CAD software
all of these remarkable relatively
speaking brand-new technologies like 3d
printing and laser cutting and and and
all these electronics that are so easy
to incorporate these days to be
inventing products and building them and
iterating and building like you know
dozens of them you know within a day
sometimes so it's great yeah I mean we
have brought the product life cycle from
years to days you know factors of a
hundred you know faster boom what's up
everyone welcome to simulation I'm your
host Don sake on very excited to be in
Boston Massachusetts still we are at gsv
labs co-create X's East Coast
headquarters we're going to be talking
about real-time innovation we have matt
cameron joining us on the show what's up
hey thank you so much for having me Alan
I really appreciate it I can't believe
that eight years ago or something like
that we were at the University of
Minnesota together yeah and now we're
both adults doing our own projects in
the world it's super cool that this
reconnection is happening after such a
long period of time flies time flies
eight years Wow
we've done a lot so which were immature
so much a better world view now yeah
yeah stuff for those who don't know max
background he's the co-founder and
president of co-create X which is
helping realize the full creative
potential of people's by strengthening
communities processes and productivity
worldwide and you can find co-create X's
link below co-create XCOM as well as
their Instagram their Twitter their
Facebook group and Max LinkedIn profile
link so let's start things off with our
question that we love asking we find
ourselves as stewards of Earth what is
your current take on the state of
humanity the state of humanity while
well
I think that this is the most incredible
time to be alive by far this it is a
magical time to be alive we have the
freedom to travel anywhere in the world
you know within like 24 hours I mean it
is it is remarkable the freedom and the
openness and the ability to express
ourselves like this is this is the best
time in human history ever it's the
safest and I think it's only gonna get
better we've we've seen we've seen so
many good and amazing productivity tools
and transportation is transforming trade
and it's a magical time to be alive in
this this state of humanity I am so
fortunate I got to experience having a
no phone and a very small little phone
that could just do text messages that
you know we all like all my friends you
know did too many text messages and our
bills went up through the roof or our
parents you know took our phones away to
the point where we are doing like
virtual reality we have virtual reality
to your machines in our pockets powered
by data centers everywhere in the world
like this is magical like oh my goodness
it's a miracle where we are right now
yeah I love your your your degree of
optimism and your degree of confidence
in progress and in creativity being
maximized right now I'm really happy to
unpack that with you because you got
this real time innovation edge to you
and your organizations and the people
that you impact around the world so
let's jump into the journey so you're
born in Madison in Wisconsin then you
move to Minnesota when you're seven and
then from there you went through the
University of Minnesota tell us about
these inputs the stimuli that caused you
to become who you are a family friends
you said we're really important you're
three older siblings warts and then of
course your outlook on the desire to
improve life and make it more efficient
productive yeah yeah for sure so I feel
incredibly fortunate because I was
always around a lot of my peers who are
also interested in
building stuff and improving things and
and I think we were we were raised in a
very unique interesting time that like
we were exposed to so many ideas growing
up that were so well thought out you
know these the first you know movies and
videos and and things that TV shows and
things that influenced us were very you
know thought out and well funded which i
think is is is it's an interesting way
to kind of grow and develop ideas
whereas today it's very very quick and
easy to be posting stuff which is also
very good in many many different ways
but I ended up studying physics at the
University of Minnesota and was exposed
to a lot of really unique product design
activities and just an understanding of
of the world and physical properties
that that was inspiring
I chose physics because it was like the
most difficult thing that I took in high
school and I was like I need to master
this and you know four years later with
a physics degree you know I do not
believe that I have mastered it by any
means certainly learned a lot and had a
lot of fun and struggled greatly but you
know it was it was the desire for for
knowledge and the desire for truth that
was was inspiring and and as I learned
more and I was introduced to different
technologies I I think I was able to to
unload some of my creative potential
using 3d printing and other technologies
that that it felt as though I was
skydiving with a world full of ideas
that could be realized you know before I
hit the ground and so that that is
definitely you know 3d printing and the
physics education has certainly played a
giant part in Who I am today I feel very
fortunate to have siblings who are in
science and and technology and in
business and just just a friend group in
general that you know is doing very very
interesting and unique things yourself
included you know it's inspiring and I
think
I mean it's it's a cliche thing to say
but hanging around with people who are
productive and who are always doing
positive things and pursuing something
that that is hopefully their own passion
is inspiring greatly and can lead
everybody you know to the next level of
their own personal accomplishment which
is hopefully tied to their happiness
yeah yet the the the importance of us
identifying what we our true self is
finds the most meaning in life and
setting that as a goal and having
mentors and the influences that help us
get there for every mind that's born
into the world so critical so cool and
that's what you know that's a lot in a
lot of ways what you're building is
co-create X and I want to hit on another
thing that you said which was that it
was kind of this you're you're when
you're in physics at the U of M and
you're also playing around with the 3d
printing tools you're really starting to
realize the full potential of what it's
like to to think of an idea and then
make it in the world like you said by
the time you're done skydiving before
you've hit the ground yeah physical
world yeah that he was a major light
bulb yeah oh yeah and then tell tell so
tell me about how that then ended up
catalyzing want to actually even before
we get to Z Mach and how that catalyzed
that tell us about this perspective that
you have with looking around you and
seeing how do i improve life how do I
make the quality of everything around me
and other people better yeah
great question I think that one
important thing is to not get
intimidated by trying to solve the
biggest problem right away it's it's
easy to think that even improving
something very small is just not worth
your time but the ability to learn from
building something small and and
reasonable is so important so the for
example when I was first introduced to
3d printing I took an incredible class
at the University of Minnesota called
toy product design with Barry Kay
Jewett's
it was it was my first
perience of a product design and using
3d printing to make an idea that we had
just thought up a reality within 24
hours I mean this was this was magic I
had never seen anything like this this
is plastic like you would see in a Lego
set
you know ABS plastic that's really
strong you know being able to think of
an idea and create it right away so our
our challenge was to create a a marble
run or be able to use recycled materials
like cans and boards and boxes to create
an intricate marble run to kind of reuse
stuff that's in the recycling right away
for toy purposes so we built a bunch of
connectors and we design connectors to
connect cans together boxes together
clips together to make these really
intricate marble runs and it
we weren't solving we weren't solving
global big problems with that but we
were learning the skills that when you
implement for long enough can actually
make a big difference like compound
interest on a yes in a bank account 10%
every year doesn't look very big after
that first year a second year but ten
years down the line 20 years down the
line you know we're young 100 years down
the line you know who knows how long
we're gonna last but this stuff really
really builds up that's a super
important piece of advice that we can't
get overwhelmed by the rule by the
massive challenges that we have to all
collectively tackle and we also have to
know the butterfly effect that we can
catalyze on a different part of the
world just through a simple thing like a
smile those massive dominoes that can go
and and yeah make impact and then also I
like how you said it is like a compound
interest when you do learn programming
or when you do learn engineering or
designing and CAD and actually 3d
printing something immediately when you
learn these processes it makes you a
more well-rounded person going into
every single industry entrepreneur
artist application you do after that
yeah at LinkedIn time
so then the the destroy product design
class the physics the 3d printing all
the tied you into even starting your
first company and this company
z mock so you were doing you've been
doing it seven years now that's catting
four companies design engineering firm
and packaging design now so teach us
about z mock yeah so me my my friends in
college started z mock to actually turn
a fireplace into a dancing stereo so the
flames dance to music and it's it's
really incredible it's actually based on
a science experiment called the Rubens
tube that's developed by physicists in
the you know early 20th century and it's
a it's as simple as taking it to
drilling some holes into it putting a
propane connection on one end and a
speaker to the other end that's right
and this the compression and contraction
of sound waves depending on whatever
song that you do will actually make that
the the flames bounce up and down so we
were like why hasn't anybody made a
sweet fireplace like this they build
these giant hotels with these linear
fireplaces and none of them danced music
so we pursued that you know we we
learned very quickly how expensive
getting UL testing you know bomb
proofing some of these things is right
it's very important to make sure that
these are safe and make sure you have
the the proper insurance for something
let's dealing with fire and you know
closed containers so we we made a lot of
progress we actually invented a couple
ways that really solve some giant giant
problems of this but at this time you
know I was just graduating I was I was
really pursuing my passion which is 3d
printing and and just building stuff and
ended up getting a job at stratasys
which is the world's largest 3d printing
business at the time and and that
project kind of fell at the wayside
however I do you know if anybody's
watching this and they want a cool
project to do please do that or I'm
gonna do it at some point because it's
still so awesome and I want to see
my fireplace dance music someday that's
right it'd be great in San Francisco
with you I'm sure Minnesota it just gets
too cold for like fireplaces I think
Brandon ran into some some outdoor
issues with the weather out out in the
north there's and this is another one of
those things where you're looking at
something you're like how do we make it
more exciting more engaging entertaining
these types of things and then so since
then it's been doing a lot of packaging
design design energy engineering and
whatnot but you also took that job three
years with stratasys applications
engineer manufacturing thousands of
parts which also led you to doing an
adjective
role at the University of Minnesota
where it would you actually taught the
first 3d printing class there yeah I had
a remarkable opportunity while I was
working at Stratasys I was an
applications engineer which and in my
experience was was perfect we learned
about all of the different ways that
things are made injection molding blow
molding casting forming carving all
these different manufacturing methods
and where 3d printing fits in the life
cycle of these traditional processes so
so we learned a lot a lot of
manufacturing methods and and how to
design for those those manufacturing
methods using the the new and improved
freedom that comes with 3d printing and
so from there I had an opportunity I met
a gentleman who was one of the I think
he was a faculty director at the College
of continuing education whose name was
also Mac and like we just connected
right away because they're both of our
names were Mac and like I haven't met a
Mac in awhile so anyways like it just
like worked out really well we
collaborated on the syllabus and
implemented a really sweet program at
the University of Minnesota while I was
working at Stratasys to introduce people
to all of these do new methods and we
actually did something that I believe
fully in which is give somebody the
power to pursue their passion and the
tools to pursue it quickly and just let
people
joy let people embrace what it is that
they want to do that's that's where you
get the best out of people you get the
most out of someone when they're doing
something that they love to do and these
tools are making it quite easy to do
that yeah it's it's powerful when you
put it in that perspective because when
someone's in that state of creative flow
where they're finding the most meaning
and what they're doing on a
moment-to-moment basis the per the
productive output is just unrivaled
compared to anything else that someone's
doing in tools like 3d printing and like
the class you were teaching we're
powering people to be able to to
creatively flourish like that mm-hmm so
you also I want let's teach about this
let's have you teach about this on the
way to co-create X there's dozens of
ways to do 3d printing and 3d printing
and additive manufacturing are
synonymous yeah ok and then third but
this is 30 years old most people we're
thinking like those the brand new it's
30 years old yeah and that this is
layering materials and building new
shapes building new lattice structures
building new cooling channels bending
these materials yes fascinating yeah
it's it's so cool and I really inspire
anybody who's interested in getting into
3d printing first start with learning
CAD software computer-aided design
software or other methods to convert
your ideas into a digital file because
once it's converted into a digital file
you have the freedom to manufacture it
in many different methods but 3d
printing in general is a was first
called additive manufacturing because
instead of kind of the traditional
subtractive manufacturing where you take
a big block of steel and you mill it
down or you know could be any number of
materials and you subtract the material
this is a a method to actually start
with just the material that you need and
build it layer upon layer so in essence
I mean in general it's considered a more
efficient way to do stuff you don't need
a big block of material you don't need
to throw away as much material but what
also happens is you get design freedom
that you can just build stuff that
subtractive manufacturing can't
can't get away from so about ten
different ways to do this you can do
metals you can do foods you can 3d print
different bio plastics and you know
structures and silicones that can be
used for anything from new engine parts
to organs to plastic pieces to toys
really a lot of freedom and more and
more applications coming out any any
given day honestly um of this so yeah
hopefully that was a guy's great yeah as
a kind of a good understanding of each
student than it is it's so true that
with the subtractive there's how do you
get into the inner parts like you said
with if you can make whatever insides
you want more easily also the
applications like you said everything
from micro vasculature and organs all
the way to the aerospace and automotive
parts and yeah this is application
endless I love it yeah and it's so
accessible I I can teach somebody how to
3d print and design something that they
have in their head in ten minutes
yeah that's profound boom that's proof
you'd be doing it yourself in ten
minutes ten minutes there's a 3d printer
right there Wi-Fi connection
we're Palin we're we're good we're
making you some stuff and now okay I
love it on the software side of things
okay so CAD so computer-aided design
what are the best tools that someone
could learn and you know in that 10
minute period where they could have
realized the way that they want to
design something and have it and have it
printed yeah so just recently with this
cloud computing boom a lot of these
these software's have gone into the
cloud which means that you can just use
them on a traditional browser whether it
be Google Chrome or Firefox or opera or
Safari and this is very unique because
these are very high intensive programs
in terms of the hardware that's needed
to run these things so typically I'll
have somebody start with a either a
digital sculpting program in which you
pretty much start with like a ball of
clay a digital ball of clay and use like
grab
and you form it and you smooth it and
you can ultimately create something
that's very organic shape like a face or
a body and a good great one for that
it's called sculpt GL I usually just
google search sculpt GL it's it's the
first thing that pops up you don't have
to sign up for an account you should
totally check it out it's really awesome
you just start designing or there's one
that's called Tinkercad which is a
little bit closer to engineering
drawings but it allows you to do take
take blocks like in minecraft or circles
or spheres or shapes and very quickly
create 3d geometry from it yes and then
and then you can save it as a as a STL
file or as an additive manufacturing
file or any number of the formats and
then right when you get there you're
good to go it becomes very easy to make
it from there one step kind of further
which is engineering drawings kind of
some of the big players in the industry
are on shape which is my personal
favorite at this time and fusion 360
which is also an incredible software
both I believe have free options for
entrepreneurs and and for educators and
people in school and then there's their
SolidWorks and CATIA and that there's a
bunch of other big intensive softwares I
could talk for a while about software's
there's there's there's you know even
more like you know topology optimization
and being able to incorporate stuff like
an topology but with with that that pot
of software you know getting good at
that is like getting good at code
twenty-five years ago I mean this this
is going to blow up and it's going to be
exciting and we're going to see
improvements across the board
there is an you know an hour of code
there are all these code pushing
programs because there's big money in it
this cat is like coming soon I agree
yeah yeah get good at cat is a you know
one one perfect cat yeah so it's like
learn to code learn to CAD you know
learn to social-emotional
like these things that help with you
know business and relationships rapport
yeah interesting so the combination of
kind of like those three things are a
massive part of our future
yeah you you you indicated a couple
things there that thought is so
important one of them being that the
processing capacity that was necessary
on a piece of hardware is you know you
know you can do it in browsers because
we're doing it via cloud compute which
is fantastic so cool and then also that
you know things like the sculpt GL or
Tinkercad are kind of more of like these
basic more fundamental ones and then all
the way up to the harder ones the new
fusion 360 and Zod works and and in
topology etc so there's there's that
gradient level for expertise which is
available so go and get tinkering that's
such a good point is going to get
tinkering as soon as possible get used
to playing around if they didn't
actually go and actually take that file
and go print it to see it come alive
right away that's so awesome yeah it's
it's so cool it's so empowering and when
I was teaching a class with the
gentleman named Derek Mathers at the
University of Minnesota he would like to
tell the analogy like 3d printing your
first part that you designed yourself is
like going scuba diving for the first
time and taking that first breath
underwater we're just a new world opens
that's very that's really well said yeah
yeah yeah my my had so many other good
analogies come up to let's hit co-create
X real-time innovation sessions you've
maximizing the full creative potential
of people in one of the most accelerated
product design fashions is beautiful
like you said it's like when you scuba
dive for the first time when you take an
airplane for the first time when you go
across the world when you fall in love
the first time all these types of things
is like how can you realize that idea
and how do you have a company like
co-create x that actually does end
there's so many components of this let's
start from the from the highest level
perspective on this real-time innovation
yeah so so Kokura Dex we started this
officially about three years ago and the
the vision is to help people make a
living by being who they are and doing
what they love which is like how do we
help innovators support their passions
and be is successful as we can possibly
make them we help tap the power of
communities to help people realize their
creative dreams and my co-founder Nick
poly loves to say that a tapping the
community is is so interesting because
the more you tap into the community a
community in general the stronger it
grows right it is a resource that when
you tap into it it grows stronger as
opposed to tapping into a mine where you
mine out the materials and it becomes
less you know less materials in there
the community actually grows stronger so
we have been supporting people with real
time innovation sessions in which we're
using all of this CAD software all of
these remarkable relatively speaking
brand new technologies like 3d printing
and laser cutting and and and all these
electronics that are so easy to
incorporate these days to be inventing
products and building them and iterating
and building like you know dozens of
them you know within a day sometimes so
it's great yeah yeah I mean we have
brought the product life cycle from
years to days you know factors of a
hundred you know faster and it certainly
it requires a lot of a lot of practice
and expertise but also just you know
just just doing it just getting into the
rhythm you know not worrying about what
can't be done but instead just
consistently like you know push and
solve those small problems right break
everything into small problems and work
you know as fast and you know as wrap it
as you possibly can oh my goodness this
is so great so you take like such a good
way to put it as that when you tap into
the community grow stronger that's
there's you know coke
Dax has his own ulcers own community of
builders engineers designers ops people
executors of all sorts as well as is
working with inspiring communities
around the world to also come up with
helping with the execution of ideas of
people in those areas so you can kind of
reach out to either you know co-create X
or co-create X can also kind of pair you
with people in the local communities
that you're at yeah that's right yeah
and just one more thing about that is
there in recent years there has been a
big influx in makerspaces some call them
fab labs there's a huge number of names
for what you would call a place that you
can go and build stuff these are popping
up at schools these are popping up in
rural areas down in cities there are
places to make things but the business
models that are associated with these
places have made them very difficult to
be sustainable so co-create X's is
developing a platform and has already
developed a good portion of the platform
and and a culture that's going to make
maker spaces around the world truly
thrive on what it is that they have
access to which is the ability to turn
the community in which that makerspace
is in those ideas into reality to solve
those problems very fast so we've we've
developed a distributed social network
that you know captures generosity within
these places we've developed a an
intellectual property blockchain
application that allows us to quickly
and immutably gather the information
that that are that's generated there and
we've we've built kind of a structure
and a process for people to host these
real-time innovation sessions and
actually be inventing stuff my ideas are
so important and the the patent system
and just the ideas in general it just
needs to be improved and because we can
do these things so fast when I say these
things I mean build products or take
that idea in your head and
put it in your hand in a couple hours it
is it is becoming more and more
important to to be able to kind of
understand and feel comfortable
communicating that idea and sharing that
ideas with others so that's that's
really where we're trying to trying to
go and we have a bus that we you know
turned into a makerspace and we have a
house that we have a makerspace really
where we we did a lot of this initial
just we a lot of this initial
brainstorming of like okay well you know
what's going on here right we can't keep
up with the Joneses we'll never get the
biggest baddest laser cutter and right
when we get it there's another one that
comes out you know and so we've
developed these these products in this
culture that that we're growing in
building yeah yeah the the when you when
you take someone that in that that so
much needs double just one-on-one
mentorship and guidance of I have an
idea how do I realize it and then
there's a community around them that
helps them do a real-time innovation
session and just like that the idea is
iterated on a step further and then even
then physically in their hand or a step
into the further into the world is just
so critical and the execution is such
it's the most important than 99% of it
and ideas are everywhere all the time
and if we can actually realize them more
fully into our world faster and build
community in the meanwhile that's so
crucial now I want to hit on a couple
things as well one of the things that I
like potentially referencing quite a bit
is this edge of knowledge so we have
this massive edge of knowledge for
civilization and that we find so many
different scientists engineers people
that are at this the edge and then
artists entrepreneurs and so when we do
things like co-create X it helps us
democratize the the IDE ideation process
to create as well as then further push
that edge and open up more people to be
able to creatively go and explore there
yeah yeah couldn't agree with you more
I love the analogy of of wearing this
this spear that is ever-growing of
knowledge in it and expanding and people
are bouncing into the edge and pushing
it out a little bit and if it grows in
general yeah I think it's so so
interesting and it's it's accelerating
it's very much going way faster than it
was and there's a number of reasons
reasons why including the software
that's making this whole whole world
yeah yeah yeah it's making the world
tick okay teach us you know you you
talked on the IP blockchain I wanna
we'll save that for laughs right after
the mobile innovation bus you want to
scale that I like that idea
your drive you're driving around a bus
that has a lot of 3d printing technology
and that kind of gets kids and young
adults in and excited about about
actually executing ideas and you're
driving around yeah it's we're like the
New Age Rockstar except for we're not
like singing concerts we're going and
inventing stuff for people it's it's
wild and I encourage everybody to tag
along we stop stop by lots of cities so
we might be coming by and making over to
us yeah yeah Crete X bus yes c CX bus
yeah bus and then very good so more
buses more City stopping more cities
potentially around the world as well
having buses around the world
democratizing the technology further in
the most rural parts inspiring more
people to yeah to build mmm-hmm and then
the IP block Sheen also related
especially to like the edge of knowledge
is very interesting you mentioned
patents as well earlier we kind of prop
people up on a pedestal a lot as an
individual looking Nobel laureate or the
founder of a company or whatever but
then there's like thousands of people
that were involved in that physics edge
push or the operations push out a
company to get something done so when
you take something like two people
having an innovation session like if Mac
and I were to go and do an innovation
session on a drone right now one one a
drone application and then we were to
literally put that on the co-create X's
blah
Shayne and say that Mackin Allen had
this session it's physically there on a
ledger that's decentralized and boom
just like that now we have then we have
an ongoing ledger of our innovation
sessions yeah exactly we will have a a
hash that will last essentially forever
associated directly with that
information that we put in there and
what's really cool about the Coker decks
blockchain is that it is too inter
interact with it it is as easy as
sending an email all you have to do is
send an email to blockchain at koco.com
with the subject line as what it is that
you're sharing and an attachment and it
will immediately log that into our
blockchain I think it takes about 26
seconds and send you back the hash and
the document that has been hashed into
the POC Janus with the timestamp and
everything so we think we have the
easiest way to to interact with a
blockchain that we've ever seen le so
you and I update maybe our CAD design
and then we would submit that in and so
send the email and then eventually it
gets so integrated that it just
automatically takes that file and stores
it on the co-create X blockchain so that
it's an automatic integrative in
iterative and innovative part part of
our creative processes exactly and and
we've also incorporated a way to just
just quickly create a non-disclosure
agreement and from that because a lot of
times people just they just want to
share their ideas with somebody's going
to be helpful for them but they're they
don't want to share it without somebody
tiny a non-disclosure agreement and so
we want to make that easier as well and
we don't we don't give legal advice we
work with with lawyers and and patent
agents who help out that stuff but this
is at the very least we're taking a step
in the right direction and in practicing
what this is ultimately going to look
like as more or more of these
innovations real time innovation
sessions happen around
yeah you have a cool video about help
and thank you as well which I thought
was very profound because gratitude has
shown over and over again to increase
amounts of meaning and purpose of
fulfillment and awe and unhappiness in
life and and to to be able to do
something like push a help and thank you
culture around the world is so critical
yeah well thank thank you so much the we
found that some of the most valuable
things that happened in our in our maker
space when we had it was when somebody
gave a thank-you note these they're it's
just it just feels really good and
there's not there's not a lot of bad
stuff that happens when you know
somebody gives somebody to think you
know and says thank you for helping me
out that was that was really help me
complete the project you know patent the
invention he'll do something that I
wanted to do so we decided that we're
gonna start really incorporating that
into our culture and really inspiring
people to collaborate and celebrate the
good things the the things that were you
know need celebration so we we applaud
all those who are helping each other
with projects and saying thank you and
if you're so inspired you can say thank
you to somebody who's helped you out
with your project on cochlear Dexcom and
it's a it is it is the fundamental the
baseline culture of of a successful and
happy community yeah you mean yeah yeah
that makes me feel great when you talk
about community and creativity and thank
you and right these things coming
together are our future in so many ways
so mmm-hmm yeah we love what you're
doing and I want to want to ask you a
couple simulation questions on the way
out of the show we cover everything
fairly well I think so yeah so yeah yeah
I think so too good good all right all
right so we'll ask you for
are we in a simulation I think we're
building the simulation right now I
think we're the first about obeying we
may see in our lifetime I just watched a
cool video in VR I was a I was in the
dinosaur dinosaur land so yeah I think
that I think that we are the first I
think we're building the simulation
right now you think this is base reality
and we're building the first I think
this is base reality yeah Oh interesting
yeah okay let's do it
let's build it prove me wrong no little
poke the it--if ik probe trying yeah
exactly base or not first yeah but we
but yeah you're right that the tech has
advanced so much it's it's for sure
going in the direction of making more
simulations since it discoveries to make
you yeah I mean it's a great
conversation to have but because
sometimes life feels like a simulation
yeah yeah like we may yeah oh and here
we are now yeah exacting like enjoy
enjoying life in Boston with the the
paramount in the background at GSP labs
that's right yes yeah it's like it was
meant to be yeah no kidding that no
kidding and also the the the full
realization of people's creativity is a
critical part of the process and we're
leveling up as we create more yeah we
level up we gain more experience points
who can log that on a Ledge here along
the way that's a great wave yeah
everybody's perspective is incredibly
important to solve the problem and
everybody has has something that I'm
sure that they would love love to see
solved and we are empowered today to
help people do that and to do it
ourselves yeah yeah yeah unprecedented
rates and it's it's really time to
democratize the future more and give
people more of the tools to access to do
so and then what do you think's the most
beautiful thing in the world my
girlfriend
stephane the most beautiful thing in the
world but but in terms of science and
technology and humanity I think that
seeing someone pursue their passion
empowering somebody to pursue their
passion you know for their own personal
purpose is the most beautiful thing I've
ever seen in this room that lighting is
now helping light the fire under
someone's creative potential yeah
hey I'm hoping hopefully I'm helping you
do that as well right now and you you
absolutely great content get this make
make magic and hopefully hopefully
inspire some people yeah yeah and it's
it's it's your sowed so right that
that's one of the most profoundly
beautiful things you see someone that
has their own aha
I have the full potential to build what
I care about and build the future
together as that global community find
my role in the game together yeah inside
my character role Wow what the the
profound feeling that that catalyzes
yeah it's incredible at and it's it's
unfortunate that so many people don't
have the opportunity to pursue their
passion with with the majority of their
time and with with automation and with
these the technology is making it easier
and easier to do so but I have been you
know fully pursuing my passion for just
a couple years and it is I love going to
work every day you know everything is is
exciting and if you don't feel like that
I encourage you to to really try or
reach out to the Kokiri x community or
or anybody to help so there are people
out there willing up willing to help you
pursue that passion because we know it's
going to be your best work that you'll
ever create in life is is what you know
you you know you got to do with him a
question that we like asking is why have
we built a civilization we
people do what they don't love every
single day so yeah so then it's about
the new code deployments that make it
easier for the kids when they're born
into the world to be able to do what
they love every single day without
having to do things that they don't love
and then also like you said or reach out
to co-create X reach out to simulation
simulation series at gmail.com and reach
out to us cuz we'll love to pair you
with the you know co-create X's Facebook
group or any of the people we featured
on the show that are at the edge of
their fields so you can get going on
building and iterating and fulfilling
your your fullest into the world Mac
holy cow would have awesome conversation
together thank you so much for thank you
so much Alan again
much appreciated huge love big love
thank you to collaborate more I agree I
totally agree there's so much good stuff
to collaborate on and much love everyone
thank you so much for tuning in we
greatly appreciate it we work yes we'd
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below let us know what you're
thinking also share this type of content
with other people talk to your family
your friends online with your co-workers
about what it's like to pick up the
engineering tools and software that you
need to build immediately into the world
and have this real time innovative
process with more people and then enable
it with more people check out all of
co-create X's links below
also check out simulations links below
support the artists and entrepreneurs
and organizations you believe in around
the world help us be able to continue
communica places like Boston and having
great conversations with people like Mac
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much thank you for tuning
in and we'll see you soon